blazers throw the grizzlies by nine just  over 1 30 left in the third quarter dame  trying to work against oliver  shakes him and dame rolls in the three  so the blazers after a couple of  possessions cut the deficit to six  pressing up on him  there he is got got anthony toliver  tripping up  stops on a dime cj handles against  brooks  cj gets the screen from white side back  out to hezonja  zhonya puts it back on the floor wait a  minute loses anderson don't do it to a  mario  can't finish the highlight though as  anderson  very fortunate that the ball did not go  through the cylinder they got to give me  a warrant that's for  mature audiences only a couple of rough  possessions for anderson as whiteside  sends that one to the deck  [Applause]  14 left on the clock for the grizzlies  oh man that was legit too that wasn't  one of the ones where he steps on his  foot  and it makes him lose his balance